>> IT IS 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
IT IS DAY THREE OF THE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
YOU ARE LOOKING LIVE AT THE
SENATE FLOOR WAREHOUSE
IMPEACHMENT MANAGERS ARE
DESPERATELY TRYING TO CONVINCE
THE SENATE TO THROW TRUMP OUT OF
OFFICE BUT SO FAR ADAM SCHIFF
AND HIS FRIENDS HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO MOVE THE NEEDLE.
THE REPUBLICANS AREN'T BUYING
THE DEMOCRATS' CASE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. SCHIFF AND THE OTHER
MANAGERS DID AN EXCEPTIONAL JOB
LAYING OUT THE FACTS.
SPEAK OF THIS IS THE WEAKEST
CASE FOR IMPEACHMENT AND
HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE HOW FLIMSY
THIS CASE IS.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S ACTION IS
WRONG, IT IS ILLEGAL, IT IS
DANGEROUS.
SPEAKER WHO SHOULDN'T BE
TRUSTED?
IT IS ADAM SCHIFF TRYING TO
PERPETRATE THIS LIE ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: WHILE THE DEMOCRATS
WILL SPEND 24 HOURS GOING AFTER
TRUMP, ADAM SCHIFF REVEALS WHAT
IMPEACHMENT IS REALLY ABOUT.
>> WE ARE HERE TODAY TO CONSIDER
A MUCH MORE GRAVE MATTER AND
THAT IS AN ATTEMPT TO USE THE
POWERS OF THE PRESIDENCY TO
CHEAT IN AN ELECTION FOR
PRECISELY THIS REASON.
THE PRESIDENT'S MISCONDUCT
CANNOT BE DECIDED AT THE BALLOT
BOX, FOR WE CANNOT BE ASSURED
THAT THE VOTE WILL BE FAIRLY WO
WON.
>> Jesse: I WAS READING
KARL ROVE TODAY.
>> Dana: GREAT WAY TO START
YOUR DAY.
>> Jesse: AND HE HAD A GREAT
POINT.
I'VE MADE THIS POINT MANY TIMES
BUT I GUESS HE MADE IT IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," SO
COME A VERY, VERY OFFICIAL.
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT IT.
WHAT IF HILLARY CLINTON HAD
BECOME PRESIDENT AND THEN WE HAD
FOUND OUT SHE'D PAID FOR THIS
DOSSIER OVERSEAS TO DIRTY UP HER
POLITICAL OPPONENT?
WITH THE DEMOCRATS HAVE WANTED
TO IMPEACH HER FOR PAYING FOR
FOREIGN ELECTION INTERFERENCE?
>> Dana: SURELY NOT.
>> Greg: I REST MY CASE!
>> Dana: WE CAN GO BACK TO
REGULARLY SCHEDULED PROGRAMS.
AND IN "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
TODAY, HE CAN ZERO IN ON
POLITICS LIKE THIS AND MAKE THE
POINT, BUT BASICALLY IT WOULD'VE
COME OUT BECAUSE THE WHOLE ISSUE
OF CARTER PAGE AND ALL THIS FISA
STUFF, IT WAS GOING TO COME OUT
EITHER WAY, AND YES, WE'VE
ESTABLISHED HYPOCRISY IS WELL AT
HAND.
PEOPLE WHO HAD ONE POSITION IN
1999 HAVE A DIFFERENT POSITION
NOW AND IF THE SHOES WERE ON THE
OTHER FEET WE KNOW WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
I DO WANT TO MENTION ONE THING,
ADAM SCHIFF AND HIS COHORTS
THERE HAVE CONTINUED TO USE THIS
PHRASE THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
TRYING TO CHEAT IN AN ELECTION.
REPUBLICANS, WHEN THEY HAD A
CHANCE REPEATED SEVERAL TIMES
THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO
STEAL AN ELECTION.
I'M JUST WONDERING, IF YOU ARE
AT HOME, CHEATING AND STEALING
AN ELECTION, IT GETS TO BE A
LITTLE BIT CONFUSING AND I THINK
THE NUMBERS SHOW THAT.
THE RATINGS ARE NOT GREAT FOR
ALL OF THIS.
PEOPLE ARE SORT OF PAYING
ATTENTION, NOT MUCH.
THEY ARE PRETTY TRIBAL ON THEM.
THEY FOR THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
A HOUSE DEMOCRAT SAID THEY THINK
ADAM SCHIFF DID A GREAT JOB BUT
THEY KNOW THIS IS GOING NOWHERE
AND THEY WOULD LIKE TO GET BACK
TO BUSINESS.
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW WHAT I WAS
THINKING ABOUT, IF BIDEN HAD NOT
BRAGGED ON CAMERA THAT HE FIRED
THE PROSECUTOR INVESTIGATING HIS
SON, I DON'T THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP EVER WOULD'VE
EVEN KNOWN TO ASK UKRAINIANS TO
LOOK INTO THE CORRUPTION.
>> Juan: WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES
THAT MAKE?
>> Jesse: BIDEN IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR IT.
>> Juan: TRUMP IS ALWAYS GOING
TO BE LOOKING FOR SOMETHING AND
THIS IS THE HEART OF THE MATTER
THAT YOU HEARD PRESENTED BY
ADAM SCHIFF YESTERDAY, YOU CAN'T
JUST SAY THIS IS ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED IN THE PAST.
THE PRESIDENT IS PERSISTENTLY
SAYING IT IS A PERFECT CALL.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG, HE TOLD
INTERVIEWS, WITH SEEKING A
FOREIGN COUNTRY TO INTERVENE IN
OUR ELECTIONS TO HIS BENEFIT.
THAT IS WHAT HE'S SAYING.
WHAT YOU HEARD FROM ADAM SCHIFF
YESTERDAY WAS LITERALLY SAYING,
WE HAVE TO BE AWARE THIS IS AN
ONGOING ISSUE.
BUT I THINK THE BIG STORY, TO MY
MIND -- BY THE WAY, I THINK THE
RATINGS NUMBERS HAVE BEEN
SURPRISINGLY GOOD FOR SOMETHING
THAT IS TAKING PLACE LARGELY IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE DAY.
PEOPLE ARE PAYING ATTENTION.
MAYBE IT'S NOT A SENSATION.
IT'S NOT PRO WRESTLING, BUT FOR
SOMETHING AS SERIOUS AND AS
REQUIRING OF ATTENTION AS THIS,
I THINK IT'S PRETTY GOOD BEER
BUT I THINK THE BIG NEWS HERE
IS REPUBLICANS SAY, WHY DO WE
NEED WITNESSES IF DEMOCRATS SAY
THEY MADE A COMPELLING CASE WITH
THEIR TWO ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT?
AND WHAT WE HAVE SEEN FROM
SCHIFF YESTERDAY, WHICH EVEN
REPUBLICANS LIKE LINDSEY GRAHAM
SAID WAS A VERY GOOD JOB, AND
NOW TODAY FROM JERRY NADLER AND
SYLVIA GARCIA, ARE JUST
COMPELLING NARRATIVES ABOUT WHY
THIS PRESIDENT IN FACT, ON THE
BASIS OF FACTS AND EVIDENCE,
DESERVES TO BE IMPEACHED.
>> Katie: THE WORD FACT I
THINK IS AN INTERESTING ONE AND
ALL OF THAT.
ALL OF THOSE ON THE DEMOCRATS
I'D HAVE HAD THE LUXURY THIS
WEEK TO TALK FOR HOURS ON END
WITHOUT BEING CONTESTED BY
ANYONE, WITHOUT BEING QUESTIONED
LIKE WE SEE IN REGULAR SENATE
HEARINGS.
THEY CAN REALLY SAY WHATEVER
THEY WANT AND CALL IT FACTS WHEN
THERE IS A REBUTTAL COMING THAT
WE ARE WAITING FOR FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE BUT ON THE HUNTER
BIDEN NARRATIVE, THE ARGUMENT
HAS BEEN MADE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SIMPLY GOING
AFTER HUNTER BIDEN OR JOE BIDEN
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO SCORE
POLITICAL POINTS OR GAIN SOME
KIND OF ADVANTAGE IN THE
ELECTION.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS REPEATEDLY
ARGUED IT IS ABOUT CORRUPTION
AND THE ARGUMENT HAS BEEN IT'S
ONLY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE ALSO HAD
VERY SERIOUS QUESTION ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN'S POSITION ON
MARIE'S MOM
WHILE HUNTER BIDEN WAS WORKING O
WHILE HUNTER BIDEN WAS WORKING N
WHILE HUNTER BIDEN WAS WORKING F
WHILE HUNTER BIDEN WAS WORKING R
WHILE HUNTER BIDEN WAS WORKING I
WHILE HUNTER BIDEN WAS WORKING N
POLICY.
STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS
TESTIFIED, THAT RECORD HAS BEEN
ENTERED INTO THE SENATE FOR
EVERYONE TO SAY, THEY HAVE
REPEATEDLY SAID THAT BRE'S
REPEATEDLY SAID THAT BUR'S
REPEATEDLY SAID THAT BURISMA IS
A PROBLEM AND A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
>> Jesse: NOT GREG GUTFELD
MONEY BUT MONEY NONETHELESS.
>> Greg: YOU STARTED THIS
SEGMENT BY SAYING YOU ARE
LOOKING LIVE AT THE SENATE
FLOOR.
NOW, YOU ARE LOOKING DEAD.
DID YOU NOTICE THEY WERE ALREADY
SHOWING VIDEOS THAT THEY SHOWED
YESTERDAY?
THEY ARE ALREADY INTO THEIR
SUMMER RERUNS.
BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE
ALL THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IS
FILL SPACE.
THIS IS BASICALLY SO FAR A THREE
DAY CAMPAIGN AD AGAINST TRUMP.
THIS WOULD BE A GREAT TIME FOR
THE NEWS TO ACTUALLY DO THE
FACT-CHECKING AND SAY, THE
REASON WHY PEOPLE SAY
ADAM SCHIFF SOCKS AND
ADAM SCHIFF DID A GREAT JOB IS
BECAUSE ADAM SCHIFF IS
PRESENTING OPINION.
PEOPLE CAN DISAGREE WITH THE
OPINION, THEY SAY HE IS BAD AND
PEOPLE WHO AGREE WITH THE
OPINION SAY HE IS DAZZLING.
WE KNOW IT'S ALL OPINION.
THE PROBLEM IS WE HAVE ALL THESE
FACT-CHECKERS AND AMAZING
JOURNALISTS AND THEY ARE JUST
OVERLOADED WITH ADAM SCHIFF THAT
THEY CAN'T FACT-CHECK WHAT HE IS
DOING.
INSTEAD, WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY DISCUSS HIS PERFORMANCE.
NOT THE CONTENT, BUT THE
PERFORMANCE.
OH, HE REALLY LAID IT OUT THERE.
CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT HE LAID OUT
AND WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS TRUE
OR FALSE?
MOST TELLING MOMENT WAS THAT
SOUND ON TAPE THAT YOU PLAYED
WHEN SCHIFF SAID IMPEACHMENT IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE WE CAN'T COUNT
ON 2020 BEING A LEGITIMATE
ELECTION.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
HE'S SAYING THAT IMPEACHMENT IS
A PROCESS IS SUPERIOR TO AN
ELECTION.
NOT JUST PAST ONES IN 2016 ABOUT
FUTURE ONES.
WHAT HE IS BASICALLY SAYING IS
THAT ANYBODY CAN DO THIS.
HE IS SAYING THIS TO PREVENT A
FUTURE EVENT.
THIS IS A FIGMENT IN HIS BRAIN.
IT'S NOT EVEN REAL.
HE IS SAYING THE 2020 ELECTION
CANNOT BE TRUSTED.
THE 2020 ELECTION HAS NOT EVEN
HAPPENED YET SO WE HAVE SEEN
THIS BEFORE WITH THE MEDIA AND
THE DEMOCRATS.
THEIR ARGUMENTS ARE ALWAYS ABOUT
THE FUTURE BECAUSE REALITY IS SO
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THEY ARE
EXPERIENCED.
THE REALITY IN THE UNITED STATES
IS GREAT.
THE ECONOMY, THE STOCK MARKET.
WE HAVE PEACE AND PROSPERITY.
SO THEY HAVE TO LOOK AHEAD AND
PREDICT THE APOCALYPSE IN ORDER
TO SOMEHOW KEEP TRUMP IN THEIR
CROSS HAIRS.
BUT IT'S NOT ABOUT -- THEY KNOW
IT IS GOING TO BE ACQUITTED.
THEY KNOW HE IS NOT GOING TO BE
IMPEACHED SO WE ALL KNOW IT'S
NOT ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
IT'S ABOUT WOUNDING.
THIS THING IS ACTUALLY EFFECTIVE
BECAUSE IT'S WOUNDING HIM SO
THAT IT WILL BE A BURDEN FOR HIM
COME ELECTION.
THEY ALREADY KNOW THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO IMPEACH THE GUY BUT
THEY DO KNOW THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE STUCK ON
HIM UNTIL THE ELECTION.
>> Juan: ALLOW ME TO QUICKLY
RESPOND AND SAY THAT I THINK
FACT-CHECKERS ARE LOCKED IN, AND
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS THAT THE
BIGGEST FACT-CHECKERS ARE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THEY ARE IN
FRONT OF THE MICROPHONE AND THEY
ARE REPUBLICANS WHO SAY THIS IS
THE PROBLEM OR THIS IS THE
PROBLEM.
BUT THEY ARE NOT SAYING, HEY,
SCHIFF IS FACTUALLY WRONG.
THEY ARE SAYING WE DON'T LIKE
THE PROCESS, THE SECRET
PROCEEDINGS IN THE HOUSE --
>> Jesse: THEY DID SAY IT WAS
FACTUALLY WRONG.
>> Juan: NOW, NOBODY IS
ARGUING ABOUT THE FACTS.
BY THE WAY, SOMETHING HAPPENED
IN 2016.
AND TODAY, THERE WAS A
PRESENTATION SAYING RUSSIA
WORKED WITH DONALD TRUMP IN 2016
TO BENEFIT DONALD TRUMP AND
DONALD TRUMP ASKED FOR THEIR
HELP.
>> Jesse: TRUMP SHE DID IN
2016, HE'S GOING TO CHEAT AGAIN
IN 2020.